[Music]
wait what's the horny Tik Tok
Chef you know yeah oh yeah I already oh
yeah this dude we know this
guy
yeah I I love this
dude love him
[__] bad little [__]
D eat yeah I don't think yeah I don't
think I want to meet this guy eating the
ass of the dough after spanking it he's
not eating it he's smelling it that's a
that's just a taking a real big whiff I
thought he was doing a
little yeah that's
sequence dude just just do only fans I
know I know
like isn't that easier than this yeah
probably this takes so much effort bro
and then you can actually like you don't
have to ride the line you can just put
your dick in it yeah yeah yeah yeah just
you don't have to do this like sort of
like oh people you you just [__] the
dough
yeah no way he was rubbing the [__] on
an egg
yeah
that's so lame
dude holy
[__] yeah it's
lame yeah it's
lame that little jiggle of the
sauce by the way my lats look awesome
this one right here
yeah yeah you know when your girl be
like I'm in a [__]
[Laughter]
that's just a bodybuilding progress shot
yeah
yeah oh this to make a donut he's going
to eat out the Donut oh my God all right
dude yeah we were joking about them like
being like kids Donuts like why is he
decorating them like children would want
to buy these for Halloween ooh this
one's a brain cuz that's who's
commenting on this [__] yeah [__] 17y
old yeah yeah
yeah yeah so he has two doughnut shops
in Australia is what I found out yeah so
I think that's the video is we go to one
of the doughnut shops and then we buy
the donuts and [__]
them if you won't do it I'll [__] do
it when I originally saw him I was kind
of like he is so over the top that he
must he must be like
self-aware n in that this is like
supposed to be sort of Comedy like that
one like he he pushes his mixer down
like he's getting head from
it like it's so absurd that it's
funny see he didn't even push it down on
that one sometimes like you know how you
can put the head up on the mixer he goes
like and then he'll do like a couple
times and is like okay that you're
getting head from your
mixer
what but I think then he posts the
shirtless Beach ones and he's like oh no
this is like 100% thirst trap and
nothing else yeah yeah yeah be a real
man dude take the ball out put your dick
in the [__] mixer and turn the mixer
on yeah turn the mixer on let that [__]
just grind your nuts that's the human
Edition that's the human version of the
chicken thing yeah
yeah getting your meat slapped around by
that
thing this is crazy
dude oh what what's this comment I came
from Cody CO's video uh I came from the
guy was spreading butter on toast and
now I see what those comments mean meant
came from the Penguins video Cody
brought me back I came from Sebastian so
everyone's doing it now damn they came
from your video that's crazy they didn't
even come from this guy I know I feel
like this is the one you'd probably come
from yeah oh there's just something that
gets me going about a guy in his off off
yeah talking
talking I'm thankful for your videos I
Came because of you just Facebook moms
don't let my husband know I'm touching
myself to you I wish I was that mixer
I've never wanted to be a mixer more
than I do right now oh my God call me
mixer cuz I'm going down on you
honey oh I would have given you head
like that in 72 I swear to God
oh yeah and he sells
calendars oh no way click the Cameo
Let's watch
One how much is it $45 modest price
brother what it's his own
thing
[Music]
oh serly uh you'll be hearing from the
lawyers it's probably like uh you know
he doesn't want the the
fee no I I was picturing like the emails
or you know can you just say my name oh
and he doesn't want all that [__]
they're naughty they're naughty cameos I
naughty cameos yeah does he have an only
fans feel like he [__] should right
yeah if you're doing this if you're
doing cam like cameos via email you
should have an only fans no see the
Snapchat is the sus part that's sus man
I think a private Facebook is a lot
suser than I just what the [__] even is
that I just me the Target demo on
Snapchat isn't it like 11 to 13 yeah but
it's like that's what people do on
[__] that's what everyone that makes
money on Snapchat stories that's what
they do is they post like sexual [__]
that's good yeah it's [__] up that's
really
good
yeah so yeah I mean you [__] have an
only fans losing I on free money what if
the biggest irony here is that uh he's
he doesn't want to do only fans cuz he's
got like weak meat yeah I'm not [__]
watching but I'm just saying [__]
watching yeah I'm not you I'm not [__]
watching that's great never heard that
term before is a Twitter phrase but it'
just be
hilarious we just get to know him
one-onone he's like guys I can't be
public about this I can do only fans
yeah yeah I got a little meat that would
probably work too that's the thing about
only fans
yeah anything works yeah oh that's the
buff little meat guy
yeah [__] so hot I small as dick is
that's why he wants to [__] a donut yeah
I know what you
need need yeah I know what you
need it would be funny if his uh
calendar was just a bait like it's just
bread just his
recipes not a single image of him at all
not one AB in that calendar at all we
should make one of these damn that would
be a funny video
actually us sexually making one of these
doesn't have to be sexual we do need
more people hooking up on this show yeah
you can make it with him maybe nah I
think he lives in
Australia I'm just all the way I don't
want like I feel like he'd like rap his
arms around you and like show you how to
need you know and you're like get
[__] stop yeah you know he's like
smelling your neck yeah what are you
doing no I think he just kind of you
know he tried to be the star of the orgy
kind of
thing like I think you just like go to
the front of the line and like get head
from the thing he like this is how you
do it yeah we're like okay yeah he tried
to cuck us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that's when we take the blender and just
go crazy with it yeah put your dick and
balls in there and just turn it on yeah
this is how you do it
like
H you know what I
mean